what happens when you hit 2 million you
get the tattoos and it goes back to like
1.9 oh yeah what happens then yeah then
if we get to 2 million again we get
another touch
[Music]
they said that we would never get this
far no did we hit it
we didn't hit it you 1.99 what are
you doing we are at are we are we
celebrating too early are you no we need
to figure out what we're even gonna do
one point you guys are all getting
tattoos Colleen's getting tattoos with
it that's what's happening here right
we're at one point nine nine no Bart's
gonna get the same one on his other Shin
now yeah so he's gonna match now are we
really gonna tattoos bro what do you
mean are we really we said we would last
year are you a little bit are we getting
are we getting what BART we're getting
fear everyone are we getting it on the
shin though so the same spot we have to
technically for the record I wasn't a
part of that you're part of it now now
you're part of it now there's no
escaping dog and you got to get it on
your butthole
or behind the ear wait then everybody's
got to get on their bus no yeah this is
this is a follow-up
we're gonna we're gonna create the rule
right now oh no
so on like exactly like him on the shin
no technically this is what we really
said okay okay this is the actual okay
okay we said we would get tattoos if JK
was still around a year later that's
true after when we said that so
regardless of no years later after two
million wait no no when you were first
bringing up that we're gonna get tattoos
I lie a lot you said
if JK is still around a year later that
was in August so August is coming up
August is coming August is a month from
now for two million Subs we'd ever had
anything tacked down on what we were
gonna do so it was that why to keep why
do people keep saying to two million I
think it kind of gets melded because we
survived nobody thought we would
everyone lost surviving plus games
getting too real now can I change what
we're getting ready for the tattoo
careful boys those two gangsters two
gangster I don't want to get in trouble
wait I'm down for careful boys do you
really want Bart because the thing is I
already got Asian characters I'm
gonna be a whole typewriter on my body
I'm gonna be an Asian squirrel I'm gonna
be a weird stereotype
come on do you have any ink on your body
I have no ink on my body but I agree to
read to it I think I have to do it get
like a neck tattoo dude a neck tattoo
like so okay
we're getting
barks getting barks thing right here and
we all got it matching but how was that
won't that make you feel less special
why because because right now there's
only two guys with that tattoo it's cool
that Morgan look in here there's more
idiots than you should hear everybody
dude and I'll get the I'll get the
double ones
it's extra stupid
why can't you just get your butthole
tattooed hey guys I'm gonna put my two
weeks notice in now
I quit now
you could get it on your calf so it's
different I know you wanna it's like
presentable you know just so you guys
know the DMS and the DMS in the oh they
know JK
constantly sending reminders about hey
the tattoo is coming up get the tattoo
August is coming we have to two M sub oh
it's in August well the thing is
originally we the correct thing is that
we said we would get it a year from now
so that would be this coming on the
timing might line up what but people
people have tended to equate that with
two million Subs it's almost like one in
the same and Verizon that he would get
his in English I said that
that's right now this is another
reminder yeah because I thought it was
funny oh no but I would want to match
with you guys
are we really crazy we have to do it
because it's such a good if
you're not a writer just say so right
now just leave and never come
back I said I put my two weeks already
Nick let's go you don't have any tattoos
get the out of here we can escape
now just the one right here
I thought you were pointing to your
butthole oh okay that's I think that's
good
I will never Welch ever so
you either get birds on the shin or you
get a stamp of fear everyone now
we gotta do all the same yeah we gotta
take a picture together
Anthony has to get it too you think
Anthony is gonna I think Andy's gonna be
in Indonesia
I think I'm also going to be in uh it's
gonna be a bali dude hey would you get a
chat with us yeah she is she'll do you
have to bro yeah if it's not on your
getting all your knuckles bruh yeah on
your knuckles yeah yeah neck Blaster you
already got one here yeah yeah bro we
get in our Shin does that hurt no
is easy if you do if you do Shin we'll
agree to let the bubble thing go yeah
that's true
yeah don't you dare do this
who was in the video when we when we
talked it was all Colleen
it was the fully assembled careful boys
yeah it was us and Anthony technically
unless I'm subbing for Anthony so
technically I'm not well
Anthony's gone you have to sub for him
for his leg
Anthony please you're gonna be Anthony's
leg hey did your tattoo hurt on your
shin I mean all tattoos hurt yeah but
like more than the others no in some
areas hey Nick is it your first tattoo
first tattoo oh you're gonna love it I
think the inside like the actual
sensitive areas hurt this is not it's
not too bad you know around the shin it
burns it's not like pain I start crying
I'll be fast this is fast it took like
30 minutes that'll be a great JK
Adventure I think I think it's so should
we schedule at like a tattoos shop let's
just say we already have tattoos or down
they're like well dude really multiple
artists have messages saying I got
homies I got homies that are tattoo
artists okay we'll do what we'll do
we'll all have an artist doing it
simultaneously and we'll record it I
need to pick my artist
no it's all gonna be great because it's
gonna come out with anyway I'm
picking the artist for Anthony what the
am I saying this is the shittiest
artist is that a shitty job it looks
good it's just the font wasn't a
Japanese
dude I have two of them
who's walking beside you like maybe the
person on your like left-hand side
didn't see that tattoo so the person on
the right hand side has an opportunity
to know that you fear everybody yeah
that's true the haters were so short we
were going down right and even we said
we were going down but that's why we bet
a tattoo on our body forever to say that
maybe it wouldn't happen but we thought
guarantee there's no way this place
survives but now we get to say the
haters was so wrong
and now when we get these tattoos
they're going to be burned up
they're gonna be molded because not only
are they molded but we also gained
subscribers they thought we was dying a
plane going down a ship sinking an Ocean
Gate getting crushed perhaps
instead a Phoenix Rising above right
gaining Subs gaining tattoos at the same
time new tattoos bro first timers even
both first timers right here
I'm gonna bite on an old-timey leather
belt while I get is it on the right leg
or the left so I think for you it
depends if you want to if if we all get
get one then we'll all get the right one
right let's do right I don't think I can
do the left I had I think oh yeah I have
something there I have an unfinished
tattoo there gotta be somewhere like
hideable no you want the world to see
that's got to be the same place yeah
we're proud to be it it's okay I'm not
part of this anyways it's for Anthony
I'm speaking on Anthony's behalf I can't
believe Bart's gonna get it on a
southern place I was just joking about
that that's so good it's something that
you threw away in a bit and now it's a
forever thing on his body for everything
because then it's like it's not fair
that we all got to get it that's not
fair it's not fair
[Laughter]
I say we do this right
okay we all get the tats
and then the next week we kick Nick out
that's so good yo Hey look it's just not
working out everyone hates you no one
likes you on the show hey hey Nick can I
talk to you outside
we gotta go we can leave now um we're
not showing up tomorrow yeah we're not
gonna be here right is that good that's
good I love you it's a move we made a
blood leave the channel it's
never reaching 2 million okay it's on
Nick's body the joke is complete
you guys all get fake tattoos I get the
real one bars just spray off in the back
you're like oh what the you guys
is that like a uh at all a big deal that
like is hitting two million subs for JK
news is pretty good we never celebrated
for any sub-hitting I know
I'm patting on
right no that's actually that's actually
style right yeah we're supposed to pop
it up and win was it 100K or something
or a million or yeah we're gonna finally
do it I don't know but that thing is
that's so good that's no it's like a 13
year old champagne that would happen and
it's expired we're gonna try but like no
we brought it to Vegas remember and we
read it and then it was like it's
expired and then we looked up can you
drink expired champagne they're like no
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
pop it we're gonna we're gonna pour a
big glass for it
and then all gonna not drink it we're
watching drink I'll throw him back oh
good okay I wonder if it'll pop it's so
old like there's no more carbonation
yeah it's all flat it's like not it's
not like wine right like wine it's like
aged and yummy yeah it tastes like
vinegar but hey we'll just have the
dancer try it and then we'll okay
so did both of you it will be your first
tattoos That's crazy dude I was telling
tip about it she was like you're gonna
get a tattoo with them and I'll get a
tattoo with me first oh will you do that
first hurry up you got till August you
can't get a tattoo yet oh why does she
want a tattoo no she just was like she
was I think she was being funny she was
wearing a joke what are you guys gonna
match and get I don't know you guys want
to get matching tattoos with your lovers
she can't cancel I put Nikki's name on
my body somewhere for sure sure
how about Nikki's property
like an Old English
only if you're killing me at the same
time
yikes is um did JK news ever have over
two mil at any point oh no no it's
always like almost there and it dies and
it goes
1.94 1192. what's the clock is this the
closest we've been it went like this it
was like this
thank you
dude that's crazy then man yeah it was
like a flight to Vegas you think you're
going to New York and then you just go
right down
why would you anyone think they're going
through so true I booked a flight to
Vegas but somehow I still ended up in
Vegas do you remember back in the day
where you just could buy the paper
ticket at the airport and then yeah and
if you just walk on the flight but then
also like you can walk on and be on the
wrong flight too yeah you could totally
get on the wrong plane yeah back in the
day yeah that was fun man so we're gonna
do this huh dude I love that our we got
a b-plus score what does that mean it
means we're not good enough is it like
social blade if we had Asian parents
it's over yeah we're dead it's over it's
over that's pretty crazy man I didn't
know that I thought it at least at some
point it was over two mil and then
dipped does it give you an exact number
of how many subscribers yeah
it is
I don't even know where to find them
wait go to about yeah you're in about oh
if in about it doesn't have a how do you
always know which which question to ask
wait wait wait I know exactly this
guy yeah my mom taught me how to
do this it's okay you guys could also
just be like no and then move on what
happens when you hit 2 million you get
the tattoos and it goes back to like 1.9
oh yeah what happens then yeah then if
we get to 2 million again we get another
touch
well it was never a 2 million numbers I
think it was to survive a year
hey don't they don't doesn't that happen
like real time yeah so you can see it go
up dude if if all of you guys just tell
one of your other friends to subscribe
it'll blow past two it's like a pyramid
scam yeah please you tell your family
who really wants a tattoo because his
first tattoo needs to be there yeah it
needs to be Japanese tell your friend
don't worry it's like a pyramid scam
just you know subscribe and then tell
your friends dude look at that
Colleen's gonna get one too it's
actually one nine nine three five one
eight okay so socialblade sucks
you could see it live yeah there is a
live one that works we're only 6 500
away from two mil let's watch the live
one we can see it move up and after this
video if they if each person took a
friend this social blade probably got
too big for their brother just say like
okay live YouTube subscriber counter
okay okay social Blade's the one that
came up go down yeah okay and then put
in the just kidding news yeah just
kidding this and it better move
it's a zero
oh it did go
199.4719 holy hey you just saw 1993
oh oh they lost they dropped out they
just stopped they stopped
17.
I thought it went down oh just went up
on oh we just gotta subscribe I've never
even this is good content yeah sure this
is what people are subscribing for yeah
yeah this is good that's pretty
cool man yeah where did all those
millions of views go because our videos
get like 40 000 views is that the norm
on YouTube though oh yeah notifications
too yeah turn on your notifications
we're bad at telling people yeah hit the
Bell like And subscribe dude
because all the new YouTubers are gonna
say all that I like it turn on the
notifications
can we finally get careful boys merch at
two mil yeah yeah let's just do that we
can I feel like oh did Orion post like a
few options and people were either it's
gonna cost some moolah cost a little bit
of bread yeah or we just Teespring it
make them all pay for oh we just
lost we just lost a subscriber dude
we're talking about merch and we lost
one maybe we're gonna talk about merch
yeah let's not talk about merch you guys
ever been on Teespring by the way nice
super tight it's tight but the
shipping is insane
can't keep talking about Merchants don't
talk about Teespring any don't talk
about Teespring oh we got okay stop
talking about talk about your feelings
Nick yeah oh no no no no the viewers
don't like that no no
Nick is a hit in the gay community
[Laughter]
let's go
talk about Steve Step Up Nikki's head
come on come on come on come on this is
a fun game I like this game please
nothing oh